[Musique]
je vous présente le garde champêtre de
guiry en vexin dans le val d'oise
madame marthe solide et oui c'est une
femme qui remplit les fonctions de garde
champêtre dans ce tranquille petit
village de 120 habitants est située à
une cinquantaine de kilomètres de paris
et à 15 km seulement de la gigantesque
ville nouvelle de cergy-pontoise les
fonctions de madame souliers de sont pas
très accaparante il faut le dire
elle consiste principalement à coller
les affiches de la mairie sur le panneau
de bois réservé à cet effet et à faire
de temps en temps les annonces minimes
[Musique]
dames ce biais vous êtes sûrement la
doyenne de gardes-champêtres on a des
garçons gagnent ses proches alentours il
refuse de vous faire parvenir ces mois
là on peut dire votre âge prochaine
didier migaud
j'aime leur tir rapport vous avez 89 ans
sonnés le 10 juillet
je suis dans ma 90e année y'a pas de
retraite pour les gardes champêtres
bon écoute tu connais pour beaucoup
peint par ma retraite de travail que
j'ai depuis x est un géant de retraite
et comment vous êtes devenu
gardes-champêtres ici c'est comme mon
mari était garde chanter et à sa mort ma
foi et c'est pas notre truc
personne ne voyait personne mais audi
avec madame celui qui peut le remplacer
ali muse une mère commune i les
personnes désireuses de voter par
procuration à l'occasion d'auditions
présidentielle du 26 avril 10 mai 1981
sont informés qu elles peuvent
s'adresser dès maintenant
au début on auprès du tribunal désormais
madame soleil m habite vraiment au
centre du village de guérir avec ça tout
près du château mme est juste derrière
l'église
[Musique]
on est ici alors dans la pièce où vous
vous trouvez le plus souvent ah oui
plutôt à part la cuisine jean louis
chargé d'accueillir jebba salle où j'ai
accoudoirs s'il ne vient pas
ouais bah oui et puis il ya ce moment où
j'écris pensez vous que je vous dise que
j'ai créée j'avais peut-être pas sam
lapointe disent non à cet homme qui vous
a dit que j'étais pour huit nouvelles
des poèmes
j'en ai quelques-uns à la wii vous
pouvez nous en donner un comme ça de
mémoire on devait voir non parce que je
te sens dîner je les comprends rien à ça
j'ai des inspirations je les écris me
demandez pas eu le rapport à ce que j'ai
été impérial
on m'a dit que les vrais poètes c'est ça
vous vivez seul ici ah oui oui tout seul
tout tchad tout seul vous vous ennuyez
pas ma foi nous
j'ai pas le temps de m'ennuyer d'avant
puis j'ai pris un caractère à m'ennuyer
j'ai un caractère attali avait gardé à
faire des farces
vous êtes ici avec tout vos souvenirs
ah oui oui chérie souvenir de deux
mariages des enfants de d'une pin le n y
est c'est la photo de votre mari le bas
oui quand il avait des soldats
il avait à ce moment-là à 22 jan aps je
l'aï connu à un mariage de mes cousins
et cousines de ses nièces et vous avez
gardé son baudrier de garde champêtre à
arue celle où père marin à la plate et
vous ne mettez plus ça non allons avant
les piles département a changé un avion
ça met plus à des oiseaux ou non le
malgré cela ça change
alors ce que vous allez nous faire
madame le lapin on t'aime douillet au
père douillet c'est bon j'ai une recette
à vous ça c'est à dire j'ai une rage et
a menacé le danger des grands-mères jeu
la modifier et et implémentation dans le
chemin de fer revenir mais c'est un
vieux jeu
livres de cuisine que je vais retrouver
au grenier et m'a plu en asie un jour de
cic fuel et ça a bien marché c'est un
trait yamar chine ça a beaucoup plu mais
beaucoup plus en plus de ça c'est que
beaucoup ont essayé jamais réussi comme
moi on ne peut pas arriver à le faire
leur revenir maintenant comme je le
faire attendre goudé vous avez bien nous
montrer comment vous faites c'est ça
j'espère que tout le monde à près de
réussir un espion aussi bien voilà bon
vous allez me dire d'abord qu'il faut
réunir pour faire cela alors de 2 kg -
agron la part dont 1 kg d'argent moi
pour vous mâcher personnes et pour moi
ça super sans lui aurait alors un gros
bouquet de persil oui une gousse d'ail
et puis il gosses wind est une quête
afin qu'un cas pas chez vous et moi j'ai
une douche à jets changer une roue stay
toute attente il a grandi oui et puis
alors là le point l'oms promet quelques
lamelles après ça je mets à luynes pour
la cuisson et à petit un doux mais
d'abord de lui lui davantage sur saône a
tout bon ensuite il me faut trois verres
de vin blanc aidera verre d'eau mais est
bien tour mois salaisons un peu de sel
alors met à l'eau grâce et puis là c'est
un peu de recul alors à la fin qu'avec
lui on monte avant de servir
vous prenez de la sauge dans une
casserole j'ai quelqu'un et vous j'ai
avec de la fécule vous mélangez avec une
liaison que vous versez sur le lapin
vous remuer la durée de mon âge dit pas
tout maintenant on va le voir en même
temps que le prêt par six alors parfois
on commence on commence d'abord par
hacher le persil et la e-lettre une tête
d'ail et beaucaire tenda entière alors
il faut naturellement l'éplucher et puis
la chute couleurs
et si oui impossible pour qu'on trouve
pas les groupes d'ailleurs accord qui
contre nathan mondiale lapin voilà bien
comme ça les côtés et on passe remercie
mon pachot persie tout ça vous mettez
mais un gros bouquet mais je lui mets
avantage un gros bouquet de persil doit
maintenant on prend la cocotte dans
laquelle va cuire ne l'a pas aussi
précis qu'est ce que vous allez mettre
dans la cocotte de l'huile oui pour
commencer et la chine à bout après bon
même temps fin de vie en par vous savez
la musique je suis bonne quantité pour
que ça ferait bien
il ya là bien comment bien un bond vers
et demi lui bien vous mettrez à la
cuillère non c'est mon couteau ballon je
prendrais cueillir trop mais là ça il
est mou attendez jamais ça on va
accueillir voyez vous ça parce que j'ai
envie de fuir
je fais une bonne nuit voilà et puis ça
va gueuler sur wii une fac chichou je
mets mon latin
voilà les vieilles la cocotte 1 ah oui
quel âge et là c'est la claque de ma
maman alors moment demande bien j'ai
trouvé caché le coin une gamine qui me
lapointe est parti une petite résistance
public pour pete mairie tous les goûts
de la garnison mais pleure pas sérieux
nitoo ah bon ça se voit que vous avez
élevé beaucoup d'entendre l'assistance
publique à l as oui on est passé 15 ce
sens et puis à leurs doutes qui m'ont
été confiées par des familles alors fait
souvent du lapin mais quand ils viennent
tu nous fais ton bon lapin matin à tampa
c'est bon la ville de vitré mis à sa
fille
le foie mais leur dernier jeu pour pas
faire pire ce sont bien deux temps vous
allez laisser là par l'offensif hommage
aux biens domique à votre goût il faut
le retour n'est pas un sujet pour ne pas
aller à fond dans son nez les morceaux à
mesure que 3 mois le maillot commuter
engone yogo perdu parce que ricco alors
je vais le couple dont la meille dans
mon lapin là de la part est de
réapprendre à votre avis les biens qui
ramène alors vous mettez un million
d'emplois en exclusivité grosses
dépenses inutiles à lyon ça va bien ils
trouveront ce prêt trop alors ne remue
afin de lutter pour un apple avec le
lapin
laissez dorer le moigno matin c'est m
mettez un petit tableau ordinaire amadou
mimosas mais bon
c'est toi à cuire je suis vraiment pour
l'instant tout de suite après vous
mettez l'ail et le persil oui mais en
chambre au niveau j'ai pas la peine de
lire j'ai parlé du mythe a peint jusqu'à
seront tous à être ensemble dans la
cocotte voilà tout ça va être un choc
dans la cocotte avec pour bien mélanger
et salé ensuite et je les suis rapide ou
le cno pour laisser cuire à feu doux
ah oui maintenant j'arrête le poids
qu'ils puissent bien longtemps que le
reste grippe a endurci que vrai mais
mots couverts et chaque culte du chemin
combien de temps vous allez laisser à
feu doux il faut souligner combien de
temps moi je dis il faut bien voir une
bonne de miliana quand même une bonne de
vioreau rue louis parce que j'active le
feu en dessous mais j'ai reçu ma touche
mans là que je remette dubuffet attiches
pour moi une grosse chaleur tue le
dessus d'accord autrement il lui est
resté bout du chemin ça fait des trucs
ça mais à quoi vous passez vos journées
on va je n'arrête pas ce l'église seule
la mairie le dis parce que l'église
c'est vous qui à la responsable sachez
responsable de l'église les chats c'est
ma vie ah oui là j'ai connu toutes les
voies possibles on voit vu le coeur
parce que c'était mon seul désir d'être
avec le bon dieu j'aurais voulu à 16 ans
religieuse cloître et vous avez
d'ailleurs la cité de la sainte vierge
où elle elle m'a paru une jeune femme a
parlé comme je vous parle et à l'église
vous êtes comme chez vous à l'abri chez
moi là là vraiment c'est ma maison
plus que celle ci ah oui ah oui
[Musique]
le
il ya longtemps que vous faites cette
fonction de sa tétine depuis 1970 70 et
votre travail alors consiste entre
autres à vous occuper des fleurs
puis alors un ballet libye encaustique
il et j'ai enlevé des poussières
évidemment influent bruit ni qu'on est
là et je suis chanceux lui fait alors le
dimanche pour prendre le mettre en
retard le dimanche le samedi je viens m
libre mais chut curé les chandeliers de
chaque côté qui l'a lu et puis prépare
sa page de l'évangile et c'est toujours
aussi bien fleurie d'église mais mieux
car j'ai quand je défendrai des
véritables peurs alors là c'est un
parterre lassé des fleurs artificielles
c'est vous qui avez fait les roses oui
oui et puis quand il ya des mariages
il ya pas fleur un peu autant être
heureuse oui c'est mon vrai bonheur
[Musique]
mais revenons de la cuisine le la pac
sortir le couvert qui évidemment la
liaison allod remaniant je vais prendre
de la chose de la création de lapin que
je mélange âme afin qu il avait goûté et
bien sonné et oui maman me suis jamais à
bien dire c'est qu'une source
comment pourquoi
mais plus qu'un maître dans le plat des
troubles à venir
nos prières
et vous le manger avec quazar principe
ça dépend de ce que l'on parlera moins
on peut mettre n'importe quel y que je
te réponds de terre soit haricots jeter
au beurre ou autres avec du chou aussi
c'est très bon le chou vous pouvez nous
lira des poèmes on mais oui c'est facile
ça concerne mon petit oiseau petit
oiseau rata cage la fneje tu regardes
ton petit créé entre balances en torrent
millions je te comprends tu es
prisonnier et le soleil brille tu
voudrais revoir ta famille mais que
deviendrait chantois tu sais bien que je
suis seul avec toi
[Musique]